history suggested he wouldn't recon kur
entry 12 months on 22 national winners
since Redrum in 1974 have competed the
following year without success and the
Fort Irwin odds weren't very tempting
but the roars told you the crowds had
back to tiger role in huge numbers it's
like you died and went to heaven no it's
just phenomenal I mean there was no
pressure today you didn't think he'd win
two in a row they don't win two in a row
red robe was delicious and her role is
it's incredible I'm floating on air here
everybody wanted a piece of the tiger
action he'd never looked in trouble in
the closing stages as he roared past
magic of light it's just an unbelievable
race and I love this place the people of
entry in Liverpool can be so proud of
whatever what they've created here and
God it's fantastic
mutual congratulations for owner O'Leary
and Jessica Harrington trainer of magic
of light her first ever national runner
at 72 but the winning trainer for the
third time was Gordon Elliott that wins
me really they're all the way heroes
life and their I love them dearly and
there's great souls for him how do you
top this I don't know two ounces back
next year for the hat trick the owner
said he'd be reluctant the trainer's
tantalizing verdict let's wait and see
Nick Powell Sky News entry